hemos hablado aquí de muchos vasos los
tres principales en los que debemos
centrarnos están aquí la vena porta la
arteria hepática y el conducto biliar
hepático común estos tres juntos forman
lo que se llama la tríada portal es una
de las estructuras que es muy importante
identificar en cirugía y también se ve
muy comúnmente en el hígado cuando
observamos cortes más pequeños del
órgano
entonces si tuviéramos que enfocarnos en
una sección más pequeña como ésta la voy
a ampliar para que podamos tener una
mejor imagen de lo que está pasando aquí
podremos ver que el hígado mismo este
órgano graso gigante se divide en piezas
o unidades más pequeñas que se llaman
lóbulos hepáticos y en el lóbulo
hepático tendremos muchos hepatocitos o
células hepáticas individuales que están
por aquí
rodeando estos hepatocitos tenemos una
representación de nuestra tríada portal
que incluye una rama que era parte de la
vena porta una rama que formaba parte de
la arteria hepática y luego una rama que
se unirá para hacer el conducto hepático
de modo que estos tres componen la
tríada portal ahora esta tríada portal
no se encuentra solo en una parte del
lóbulo hepático de hecho hay muchas de
ellas que rodean los hepatocitos y hacen
esta forma muy familiar tal vez la
recuerdas de química este anillo de seis
lados es lo que forma el lóbulo hepático
tiene seis unidades de la tríada portal
rodeando los hepatocitos así es como
obtenemos sangre rica en nutrientes que
entra en el lóbulo hepático de esta
manera estos hepatocitos estas células
hepáticas pueden extraer nutrientes para
el metabolismo o el almacenamiento de
macromoléculas y por supuesto los
hepatocitos son como cualquier otra
célula en el cuerpo necesitan oxígeno
para sobrevivir
de modo que el oxígeno será transportado
desde nuestra arteria hepática propia
así que suministraremos oxígeno a los
hepatocitos le suministraremos
nutrientes de estas ramas de la vena
porta que se llaman si no soy des no
escribiré por aquí los si no soy des
salen de la vena porta y finalmente
de que se extraen los nutrientes y
oxígeno y necesitemos enviar esta sangre
de vuelta a la bne hepática toda la
sangre se reunirá en este mismo centro
muy convenientemente llamado vena
central entonces la vena central que se
encuentra en medio de nuestro lóbulo
hepático tomará nuestra sangre pobre
nutrientes y oxígeno y se unirá a la
vena hepática que la enviara al corazón
para la oxigenación por los pulmones y
luego pasará por los intestinos para
recibir nutrientes en el proceso de
absorción del que hablamos así es como
funciona nuestro hígado